-John, welcome back to the show.
I gotta say, you were
our first in-person guest
when we didn't have an audience,
and now we have a full audience,
so thank you for coming back.
-Jimmy, the last time
we saw --
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is -- This is amazing.
I mean,
last time we were together,
we were wearing body condoms.
I think there were
ten people here.
-That's correct.
We were like 20 feet apart.
-They tested me in the lobby,
and I don't ever want to --
-We don't talk about that.
Yeah. Of course. Yeah. I --
-Good to have you back.
This is --
-Doesn't it feel good?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love a live audience.
I really do.
-You miss it, right?
-I do.
-You live for it. But, I mean,
that's why we love you.
But I remember you said to me,
"Jimmy, I got to be
the first guest.
If you're going
back to the studio,
I want to be the first guest."
And I was like, "Great,
but we don't have an audience."
You go, "I'm just gonna
do it just because --
Just for 'The Tonight Show'
and just for you."
And I appreciate that.
-Man, I love you.
-I know. I love you right back.
-Well -- Okay. So wait a second.
Usually,
if I were to be vulnerable,
you would make fun of me.
-Yeah.
-And that's kind of
how our relationship goes.
I say I love you,
and you say, like --
-Yeah, make fun of you.
But COVID's changed me.
[ Laughter ]
Now I accept the love,
and I give the love back.
-It must be you guys.
Thank you so much!
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you so much.
-No, I'm about to -- No, no.
I'm about to make fun.
Now I'm about to --
Now I can make fun.
I do -- I do --
I do just appreciate you.
And I -- But I want
to get into some stuff.
"Vacation Friends," congrats on,
by the way.
-We got to talk about that.
-We have to talk
about "Vacation Friends."
-Or else the bosses
will kill me.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I want to talk about --
We got -- Football is back.
-Football is back!
-It's happening right now.
So, we got
the Bucs versus Dallas.
I know you're a New England boy.
-Yeah, I was born
in New England.
-Yeah, and so
you're a Patriots fan,
or a Tom Brady fan at one point.
-I am a Tom Brady fan.
And just like Tom Brady,
I have moved to Tampa Bay.
-You actually did.
-I was there first.
I have this secret --
Really, honestly.
I have this secret theory
that Tom Brady is stalking me.
-Yeah. He's following you.
-We're both 44.
I grew up in New England.
He moved to New England.
-That's close enough.
-We've both won
respective championships
in our respective fields.
I moved to Tampa.
He followed me to Tampa.
-I'm just saying.
Have you guys ever hung out?
Have you ever crossed paths?
-No, but I see these
weird security cameras
that have been stationed
around my property,
and I think
maybe he's behind it.
-Yeah, he's behind that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This summer, you came back
to WWE for SummerSlam,
and it was honestly so exciting.
-Dude, it was great!
I had a wonderful match.
I finished second place.
-No, that's not the way --
No, no. That's not
the way wrestling works.
I'm sorry.
-Says you!
-That's not the way
wrestling works.
Roman Reigns.
It was awesome, by the way,
just to see you back there.
Because we talked,
and I was like,
"There's hints of you
maybe coming back."
And you're like, "I don't know."
Because you have --
You had "Suicide Squad."
You got the -- You had
the show that's happening,
the series
that's coming out now.
And you go, "I'm not sure."
Then what happened? WWE --
-I had a month off,
and they were like,
"Hey, you want to come to work?"
And I was like, "Do I?!"
And they said that
live audiences were back,
and I love live audiences!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But how did it feel --
how did it feel
to get back in the ring,
get the jorts back on?
-Well, I mean, that was nice.
-Yeah.
-That was nice.
-You looked great.
-There is no better feeling
than being in front
of a live audience.
There really isn't.
And I'm so grateful
to have all of you here.
I'm so grateful to be back
with a live audience.
There is no other energy
like performing and entertaining
or telling stories
or just shooting the [bleep]
in front of a live audience.
-So thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You remember --
Do you remember the first time
you actually wrestled
in front of an audience?
-Yes, I do.
-Where was this?
-It was in a gym called
L.A. Boxing in Orange County,
and seven people were there.
And I was not good.
So nothing's really changed.
-No. Yeah, right.
But did you feel it?
Were you nervous?
What -- Did you come out
and you were like --
-Oh, man.
I'm nervous behind the curtain.
Like, I'm always nervous.
I think
if you lose those nerves,
if you lose that anticipatory
excitement, like,
"Oh, I don't know
how this is going to go,"
like, you got to move on.
I think you're done
at that point.
I think you should
always have that energy.
-Because I know
you do love what you do.
-Yeah, this is fun.
-I know.
-We're just talking,
and people are listening.
This is great.
Or you're not listening.
You're texting. Whatever.
-The people at home, yeah.
-They're not listening, either.
-When you were --
-"Why is he interviewing no one?
Why is it just an empty chair?"
-They don't see you here.
But this is before
you were John Cena,
before you were a WWE superstar.
You were known as...
"The Prototype."
-I was.
Can you -- That's a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You were jacked.
-That's a crazy picture.
So, that was taken
pre-cellphone camera.
And that was a candid
by one of my friends.
I had to cover up my man bits
'cause I was going
to the bathroom.
-That is not true at all.
-No, but explain to me
the name "The Prototype."
-So I was 50% man, 50% machine,
and 100% awful.
It was bad. It was --
-It was a bad --
-It was bad.
-Well, I have video of you
trash-talking
and promoting as The Prototype.
-No way!
-And you guys, judge.
See if you remember this.
-I look
in your genetic lunch box
and find a peanut-butter
and jelly sandwich
with the crusts cut off!
I am 50% man...
50% machine!
You are 100% fatality!
[ Growls ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A peanut-butter
and jelly sandwich!
-With the crusts cut off!
Come on!
-Come on, man!
-Come on.
-What do you remember?
-That -- So, that was done --
We were --
There was a documentary crew
following us around.
And we usually have --
And this is done in --
That was in Southern California.
But when you learn your craft,
part of that
is impromptu promo class
where they just put
a bunch of people in a room,
and the job is to try
to catch you off guard.
And everybody
was kind of stumbling,
and they just asked me to get
up there and say something,
so I came up with that
on the spot
and threw it out there,
and they actually put it on TV.
So that actually -- that
"genetic lunch box" monologue
kind of kicked
the whole thing off for me.
So I wouldn't be anywhere
if it wasn't for a peanut-butter
and jelly sandwich
with the crust cut off.
-There you go. You're right.
Now -- Yeah.
-Weird story.
-Look at you now, though.
"Vacation Friends."
This is the biggest original --
Hulu original film
in Hulu history.
-People actually watched
and actually laughed.
-It's really funny.
-And I'm so grateful.
Thank you all for watching.
Thank you guys for watching.
-It's so good.
"Vacation Friends."
They're making a sequel.
Already signed up for a sequel.
-Number two.
There's number two on the way.
Which is kind of the story
of everybody's lives.
-There's number two on the way.
Just waiting
for that next number two.
-You have great chemistry
with Meredith.
You had great chemistry.
Lil Rel, we know.
-Lil Rel's the best.
-He's been on the show.
you know what I was
going to say to Lil Rel?
Because when I've seen him
do stand-up --
I saw him at this charity
he did for Dennis Leary
called "Comics Come Home"
in Boston.
And he was so funny,
but his laugh makes me laugh.
He's got like a,
"Yeh-yeh-yeh."
Or something like a weird --
He's got a weird laugh,
and he didn't use it
in this movie.
And I'm like -- That's
the secret move that he has.
-Saving it for the sequel.
Spoiler alert!
-It is so funny, though.
If I can set the stage --
Let me do my job a little bit.
So, basically,
what happens is...
Lil Rel and his fiancée --
or, at the time,
his girlfriend --
go on vacation, and he's
about to propose to her.
And their room is destroyed
because the person
who's staying upstairs
destroyed it,
overflowed their Jacuzzi.
[ Clears throat ]
And then he proposes to her.
They can't get another room.
He proposes to her.
You -- You and your wife?
-Yeah. Well, no, my partner.
-Girlfriend.
You and your partner.
-Yeah.
-Are out of control, by the way.
Just two out-of-control idiots.
-We just have a different
perspective on life.
-Okay. I think it starts
with you riding a Jet Ski
and she's doing bong rips.
-Yeah.
-Anyways...
That's how you meet
those people.
Anyways, they go, "Hey..."
-One guy. "Yeah!"
-I know. He's like, "I've done
that! I've done that!"
-"Yeah!"
-Yeah.
So then, you go,
"Hey, stay in our room.
You guys are in love.
You're lovebirds.
Stay in our -- We don't even
have to see each other."
-Yeah.
-"Just stay in our..."
And that's how
the movie kicks off,
and then
just ridiculousness ensues.
It is so funny.
Did I set it up correctly?
-What's that?
-Did I set it up correctly?
-[Bleep]. I hope they watch it.
You gave them the whole movie.
-Yeah, I know. Well, yeah.
Did I go too much?
Did I go too much? It's so good.
I want to show --
Here's John Cena in
"Vacation Friends" on Hulu.
Take a look.
-What's going on here?
-Oh. Uh, we lost the brakes
around Marietta.
E-brake did the yeoman's work
till right about now.
Yo, chief! Just in case
you need to move it.
-Thank you!
-Ha!
-So, I think -- I think
what Marcus is trying to ask
is, what are you two doing here?
-Oh! Well, you guys,
we were so confused
why you didn't call
after Mexico.
I mean, come on.
We were literally sitting
by the phone for a week
being like, "What?"
-But it was my bad, 'cause
the card I gave you -- old card.
You had no way to call.
-Yeah, so we did
a little Internet stalking,
and then we found out
you guys were registered
at Williams-Sonoma
in beautiful Atlanta.
-From there, it was easy.
Hit every wedding in Atlanta
starting with downtown,
working our way out
in concentric circles.
Classic circle-sweep maneuver.
Same thing I used
to find lost kids in the cave.
-This time,
you weren't too late, sweetie.
-That's what I'm talking about.
John Cena!
"Vacation Friends"
is streaming now on Hulu.
John and I
are going head-to-head
in a game of Facebreakers
when we come back. Stick around.